[Música]
Bienvenidos a este especial de France 24
en español cada día que pasa los
llamados para frenar el calentamiento
global se hacen más urgentes Incluso el
secretario general de Naciones Unidas
Antonio Gutiérrez describió como un
infierno climático lo que le espera a la
humanidad si no se toman acciones
drásticas para lograrlo para entender
Cuáles son los actos más urgentes a
llevar a cabo nos acompaña Javier Peña
fundador del portal hope en pie por el
planeta quien ha dedicado los últimos
años a estudiar y divulgar los pedidos
de la ciencia para preservar el planeta
Javier el cambio climático va
directamente ligado a las emisiones de
gases de efecto invernadero Qué se puede
hacer para frenarlas
el 90% de las emisiones de efecto
invernadero que causan el calentamiento
global se resumen en estos cinco ejes de
mayor a menor
alimentación y uso de la tierra que
incluimos la deforestación electricidad
industria transporte Y por último
calefacción y refrigeración de edificios
tenemos que poner en marcha una batería
de soluciones para reemplazar las viejas
prácticas intensivas en combustibles
fósiles y destructoras de la naturaleza
por técnicas más avanzadas que ya están
disponibles y que además suponen toda
una serie de ventajas económicas
sociales y ambientales
en materia de alimentación y
preservación de la naturaleza Cuáles son
las acciones que podemos llevar a cabo
como sociedad el primer punto es de
alimentación y uso de la tierra hay
muchas soluciones que se pueden tomar en
primer lugar
frenar la deforestación que supone el 9%
de las emisiones
reducir el desperdicio alimentario que
actualmente tiramos un tercio de la
comida que producimos y de aquí viene en
el 10% de todas las emisiones Y por
supuesto reducir el consumo de carne
para reducir la cantidad de tierra que
necesitamos para alimentar a la
humanidad y poder restaurar ecosistemas
y permitir que los ecosistemas empiecen
a capturar ese carbono y a poner en
marcha esa función de equilibrio
climático que estaban desarrollando y
que nuestra voracidad está quitándole
cada vez más terreno a los bosques y a
los ecosistemas emitiendo carbono y
privándonos de esa de ese Sumidero de
carbono crucial que son los ecosistemas
los suelos los bosques y la vida en la
tierra
echamos décadas de pedidos de pasar de
unas energías más contaminantes a base
por ejemplo de energías como
combustibles fósiles a unas energías más
limpias Cuál es el paso que tenemos que
dar para caminar de una vez por todas
hacia el futuro en cuanto en cuanto a
electricidad se da ya la paradoja de que
la renovables la energía solar y la
eólica son ya la fuente de energía más
barata que ha existido jamás Entonces
estamos
en la situación de que aunque no hubiese
crisis climática habría que hacer esa
transición energética hacia la
renovables que ya se ha demostrado que
son plenamente capaces de proveernos de
toda de toda la electricidad que
demandan nuestras sociedades y además
ahorrar energía y abaratar el coste de
la electricidad y por tanto el coste de
todo Es una transición que tenemos que
llevar a cabo de forma rápida por muchas
razones Y esta es la parte relativamente
sencilla de
una transición de la transición verde no
hay excusas para poder para seguir con
el carbón para seguir dependiendo del
contaminante gas fósil y ni a nivel
económico ni a nivel social ni al nivel
de salud Es una transición que tenemos
que acelerar drásticamente
qué capacidad tienen las energías
renovables en este momento para dar
respuesta a las demandas de la sociedad
actual renovables ya están preparadas
para asumir toda la demanda energética
de la humanidad ya hay más de 300
estudios científicos el más alto nivel
que confirman que es posible
proveernos de Electricidad para todos
los usos energéticos de nuestra sociedad
de forma estable
combinando la renovables con el
almacenamiento energético que ya está
muy desarrollado y que no solo sería una
ventaja climática sino que además se
ahorrarían varios billones de dólares
con b a nivel global es una cuestión que
tenemos que acelerar por muchos motivos
y que no hay tiempo para las excusas
tenemos
un poco más de siete años hasta 2030 y
las emisiones relativas a la
electricidad y a la producción
energética deberían llegar a cero en
2030 y sería perfectamente factible la
capacidad de producción de países como
China o como Estados Unidos de
renovables y ahora Europa que está
apostando por la industria de los de las
renovables ya es perfectamente capaz de
sostener un crecimiento exponencial
otro de los cambios necesarios que usted
mencionó al inicio fue una
transformación en la industria Qué se
puede hacer para cambiar uno de los
sectores que están más ligados a
intereses económicos y Por ende también
es mucho más difícil de cambiar
en cuanto en cuanto a la industria que
representa el 21% de las emisiones de
efecto invernadero aquí tenemos grandes
oportunidades en primer lugar La Apuesta
por la economía circular que es mucho
más eficiente y tiene enormes ventajas
que permitiría reducir nuestro impacto
ambiental de forma drástica Y en segundo
lugar dos elementos clave que es la
producción de cemento y la producción de
acero que representan en total el 8% de
las emisiones globales aquí ya hay
soluciones de producción de acero y de
cemento que son o neutras o muy bajas en
emisiones de
CO2 y es el momento de escalarlas y de
reemplazar
los elementos industriales antiguos por
las nuevas técnicas y por el nuevo
paradigma de salir de esta visión de la
producción
de espaldas a la naturaleza a una
economía circular a una industria
circular con inteligente y con impacto
que en algunos casos puede llegar a ser
positivo sobre la naturaleza y sobre el
clima tenemos todo un abanico de
soluciones que implementar
respecto al transporte hay ya soluciones
alternativas que se puedan implementar a
gran escala
en cuanto al transporte ya estamos
viendo que las medidas de
aumento de transporte público de la
movilidad ciclista en las ciudades y de
conexión de las redes ciclistas con Los
Grandes núcleos de transporte público
permiten que la gran mayoría de nuestros
desplazamientos se puedan hacer sin
emisiones de efecto invernadero con con
transporte público y luego estamos
viendo ya como el coche eléctrico los
camiones eléctricos los autobuses están
disparándose en muchas partes del mundo
en Noruega ya son el 80% de las ventas
de los nuevos vehículos son
eléctricos y estamos viendo como esta
cifra Se dispara en lugares que en los
que hasta ahora estaba un poco rezagada
como en China que llegan al 30% y vemos
Que Europa y otros y otras regiones como
América Latina empiezan también a
en países con estaciones la calefacción
y el aire acondicionado son factores
altamente contaminantes Cómo puede
influir la planificación de los
edificios a bajar las emisiones que se
producen en edificios de viviendas
oficinas O otros establecimientos aquí
tenemos una cuestión muy interesante que
es que por un lado tenemos que cambiar
la fuente de calor o de frío de los
edificios que aquí ya las bombas de
calor de aerotermia se están disparando
de forma exponencial para reemplazar al
gas
al gas que cuyo precio es disparatado en
estos momentos no Y entonces se está
incrementando de forma exponencial la
transición a las bombas de calor
eléctricas para calentar el agua de los
radiadores de las casas Esto está
pasando ya en todo el mundo y aquí hay
otro elemento clave que es el de la
rehabilitación energética que
necesitamos
transformar nuestras viviendas aislarlas
del exterior con buenas ventanas con
aislamiento térmico para reducir el
consumo las necesidades energéticas en
hasta un 90% ahora mismo la mayoría de
las viviendas de europeas están mal
aisladas Estamos perdiendo energía por
las ventanas por las paredes y por los
techos y aquí se puede movilizar toda la
economía como ya está pasando en varios
países cuando se hacen estímulos
gubernamentales para facilitar el
aislamiento energético de las viviendas
subvencionándolas vemos que toda la
industria de la construcción se moviliza
en masa hacia la transformación del
parque de viviendas hacia cambiar
ventanas hacia aislar las fachadas y los
tejados y que toda la economía despunta
en esa dirección de reducir el consumo
energético aquí podemos reducir las
emisiones de forma
muy considerable Y tenemos ya la hoja de
ruta encima de la mesa solo Hay que
seguirla
así llegamos al final de nuestro
programa le agradecemos a Javier Peña
por estar con nosotros en esta
entrevista y a ustedes por acompañarlos
los esperamos con más información en
France 24 y France 24.com Hasta pronto
[Música]